when we consider arguments in the bigger
picture
good reasons for our beliefs sort of the
core of critical thinking we should
understand when conditions are necessary
or sufficient and how necessary and
sufficient conditions might differ let's
start with necessary conditions think of
it this way if a is necessary for B then
B cannot be true unless a is true in
other words B is true only if a is true
a necessary condition for streaming a
YouTube video is having an internet
connection you can only stream a YouTube
video if you have an internet connection
a necessary condition for becoming
president in the United States is being
at least 35 years of age you can only
become president if you are at least 35
years old the conclusion is only true if
the necessary condition is true you
cannot have be without a but sometimes a
condition automatically establishes a
certain conclusion which is actually a
different concept that we call a
sufficient condition if a is sufficient
for B then a being true by itself is
enough to make be true or to put it
another way if a is true then B is true
if a then B if you have access to
YouTube you can watch the David Pakman
show if a US presidential candidate wins
270 electoral votes he or she has enough
electoral votes to become President a
necessary condition for a conclusion is
not always sufficient for that same
conclusion and vice-versa a sufficient
condition for a conclusion is not always
necessary here's an example of a
condition and that is necessary but not
sufficient by itself for someone to
become a United States Supreme Court
justice it is necessary for them to be
appointed by the president but that's
not sufficient they must also be
confirmed by the US Senate here is a
condition that is
sufficient but not necessary being born
on US soil is sufficient for status as a
US citizen but it is not necessary many
people like me are born in other
countries and become naturalized US
citizens later in life some conditions
are both necessary and sufficient for a
conclusion this would mean that the
conclusion statement is true if and only
if the condition is true being an
unmarried male is both a necessary and
sufficient condition for being a
bachelor for example you can't visit the
capital of California unless you go to
Sacramento you can't win a US
presidential election with 538 electoral
votes unless you win all of every
state's electoral votes having 538 votes
requires winning all electoral votes in
every state so winning all of every
state is a necessary condition and
winning all the electoral votes in every
state automatically establishes that you
have won 538 electoral votes so it's
also a sufficient condition there's
nothing else you must do in order to win
538 electoral votes in science a
necessary and sufficient event is
considered a cause and the resulting
event is considered the effect some
conditions are neither necessary nor
sufficient for the conclusion being a
lawyer is neither necessary nor
sufficient for being a politician many
politicians are not lawyers and being a
lawyer does not ensure that you will be
a politician so it's important to be
able to discern when these are being
misused when a sufficient condition is
being mistaken for a necessary condition
or vice-versa understanding the
difference between these types of
conditions and their applications to
arguments is another fundamental skill
in recognizing good and bad arguments in
yourself and in others this miniseries
has been made possible in part by
brilliant you're watching this video so
chances are you have
genuine interest in logic philosophy and
problem-solving want to further your
mastery you should check out this
fascinating online learning service with
brilliant you can solve hands-on puzzles
and problems developed by professors and
expert professionals from all over the
world brush up on your skills when it
comes to logical fallacies syllogisms
deductive reasoning game theory and
other domains of philosophy math and
science quickly become and all-around
better thinker sign up for free by going
to brilliant org slash critical thinking
I've put a link in the description under
this video and the first 200 people who
visit brilliant org slash critical
thinking will get 20% off an annual
Premium Membership visit brilliant org
slash critical thinking